ambassador i will say frankly i'm one of
the people who thinks you should be
expelled from this country
and i believe that it's to do with the
policies of your state
if i was jewish and i'd never step foot
in israel i could claim citizenship
there tomorrow
but six million people whose origins are
in what you now call israel
who were forced out in 1947 or 48 do not
have that right
isn't that part of the reason why the
palestinians are in dispute with
israelis because you deny them the right
to return to their homes and to their
land
and their villages and that they have a
legitimate claim even under
international law to return but you deny
them that right
why do you deny them that right and why
do you give that right
to other people who have no connection
whatsoever with the land
whether you call it israel or whether
you call a palestine why do you continue
to seize land if you're serious about
oslo and the two-state solution
which under that agreement islam
designated to be palestinian land
500 000 people most of which has taken
place since oslo you allow that to
happen why do you allow it to happen
if you're serious about giving this land
to the palestinians it's absolutely
extraordinary are you not just taking us
ambassador for idiots that you can
say with a straight face we're serious
about peace but while we're serious
about peace we're going to seize
palestinian land
and you expect the palestinians to sit
back and do nothing about that now you
know what the palestinian
people have been asking for far less
even than some people would ask for
because i believe the whole apartheid
system should be dismantled but what
they've asked for
is to lift the siege of gaza just to
lift the siege of gaza let them have an
airport let them have
uh ports let them not be dictated to by
a government for whom they do not vote
as to what can go in and out of their
territories whether they will have power
whether they will have clean water
whether they will have medicine
what makes you think you're allowed have
nuclear weapons and the fourth biggest
army in the world
and this is destruction on the people of
gaza but they have no right to defend
themselves they have no territorial
services
would you ask questions how do you
justify
that all right how do you justify those
double standards very lastly ambassador
people like
bishop tutu nelson mandela and i will
certainly describe your state as a
apartheid state with different laws for
people depending on their race or
religion
for example at checkpoints going into
the west bank
there's a channel if you're israeli or
european and as a channel
if you're arab just because you're arab
if you came into dale aaron and they
stopped you and said are you jewish oh
no sir you can't come in through the
same entrance
as irish people or european people
because you're jewish
you would call that racism an apartheid
you practice that with your checkpoints
and your military barriers and your
apartheid
wall how can you justify